[Music]
you have supported so many iconic looks
of the year so I wanted to show you a
couple of your iconic looks and get your
feedback on them so this is a fit check
so of course this is the infamous
Playboy photo shoot did you know that
this was going to be such an iconic no
of course not you never really know
what's going to happen in your career
and you hope you do well you hope you do
good but I just remember when they asked
me to do that I said I would not do a
spread if you're part of an expression
right uh you know I never you know I
didn't want to do that I said I'll do a
interview and I'll do a cover if you
really want me to and I did that and I
think it's funny I look at it I was just
a little little chunky little thing
that's so good I love everything about
it okay this is the premiere of nine to
five back in 1980 yeah with Jane Fonda
Lily Tomlin here and then of course you
three again at The Primetime Emmy Awards
what has this friendship meant to you I
had such a good time
you know we should do that more often it
has meant the world to me as I hope it
has to them it's it was great us working
together that was my first movie we got
to be friends enjoyed working together
we're all different but we're all
professional you know we all know who we
are and what we are and they know me
well enough to know you know I'm I'm
just gonna be me whatever that is and
we're all like that but I've stayed in
touch with them Through The Years and
love them both to death we help each
other with our Charities and different
things through the years in September
Jane revealed she was diagnosed with
Non-Hodgkin's lymphoma and had begun
chemotherapy treatments how important is
it to be super uh supportive of Jane
Fonda with everything that she's going
through right now well I'll stay in
touch with her and she says she's doing
good she says she's responding well to
the treatments and so uh yeah that was a
scary thing when I heard that but yeah
she's a tough little thing though you
know she's in good shape you know how
she's taking care of herself through the
years so I imagine some of that's paying
off now hopefully absolutely but she's
like me you know we're like I said tough
old birds and I say old lovingly because
we're not spring chickens anymore but
we're not sprung yet either yeah I love
that okay and last photo youth the
Grammy Awards with Casey Musgraves and
Katy Perry Oh yeah well that was great I
mean that whole thing like when they do
those tributes and have all those great
girls come out and sing with me and do
whatever it's just such a overwhelming
feeling to think that I'm still relevant
to the younger generation there is
something I've done has you know
inspired them so that makes me feel good
I feel like a good older sister but good
advice
[Music]